wow I cannot believe both of your
outfits today let's start with you
Khaleesi Denarius tell me about this
what you wearing
but I'm wearing Daenerys from Game of
Thrones she's one of my favorite
characters and I don't look much like
her but I had to cosplay her because
she's just fantastic yeah and she's the
mother of dragons who doesn't my dragons
why is it about the show first of all
that you love so much
well I'm a big fantasy geek I laugh as
well as cosplay so it's it's got
everything that you know that it was
Jimmy and of course I'm just getting
better and better I haven't read the
books but I'm interested to see where
the characters go now tell me a little
bit about this dragon that's on your
shoulder it is quite spectacular I have
caught him spike and I work for a
company called arty fakes and we make
foam and latex props and this is such a
custom order that he said I can take him
away for the convention sigh thank you
kneel and say yeah what goes into the
making of something like this a lot of
work I'm guessing it's all hand sculpted
from sheets phones and Costel so it
takes a long long time but I think the
results worth it and where did the
dragon's name spike come from I'm
totally not a Buffy fan apparently not
how do you think he matches up to the
nervousness dragons on the show well
they're getting bigger so you know I
just had to go that one step further
tell me what is it about the dragons
that appeal so much
they're like I just wish they were
around now sue Brianna's I want a real
one a pet one who doesn't want a pet
dragon no would you like to ultimately
have one of these at like had its own
little breathing fire mechanism of
course yeah this one does make noise but
I need to change the batteries see what
kind of roars I mean does roar yeah now
how long does it take to make there and
this one we usually make like swords and
weaponry so this we had to do enough
spare time there probably four or five
weekends yeah whatever and tell me again
what you said it was made out of foam
and latex rubber so it's completely
saved it's quite light so girls can
carry him but yeah we did Khal Drogo's
costume as well and the one I'm wearing
something a little bit a little comment
card a second and tell me a little bit
about what you're wearing as well and
this is her blue dress from when she's
just wandering around not very masculine
like Khal Drogo's we've got armor but
it's quite different for me because I
usually wear strong female characters
but this is more feminine strong
character so yeah it's nice to be in a
dress on this hot day so let's ask Khal
Drogo now your other half tell me about
this it's looking very impressive man we
were approached by The Gadget Show
actually appear on him
and we basically we wanted to do a game
of thrones anyway we have a dragon in
the making so we thought throw them all
together
I obviously her [ __ ] so I have to so we
had to bulk up a little bit and a lot
and lose a lot of weight and I'm just
basically become try go
what are you enjoying about paying drug
there's no horses around there so I
can't fall off her so as a bonus yeah
the real code drug goes over there so
hopefully you'll come over and play with
the dragon at one point seeing your
outfit yes you've seen her I think
yesterday possibly because she was
raining yesterday but I actually have
more makeup than heard today I've got a
thong on so I've got a lot of there
tell me about all the makeup on your
chest you've got like whole like blue
makeup going on there basically is what
any has on the Woking soil no it's my
cat just put on we've got a leopard belt
that's also been handmade and I did on
the task force oh yeah how hot are you
guys in both these outfits that's how I
don't know lucky I've got a floaty dress
on today but never chats not good living
shorts all year-round so for me this is
this is actually clothes this is a real
commitment to our that isn't it I mean
how are you enjoying it this weekend and
what kind of reaction are you getting
from the crowds this is my first time
here at lf-cc and I must say I'm having
them away over time you say with a bit
quieter so you could actually get a
chance to walk around the stores and
have a look and today I've got a table
because I'm cosplay guest here and I
just hopefully fingers crossed and saw
some posters yeah to help make the
costume
tell us a little bit about ulti fake
we've been around for 60 years now the
creative director has been in the
industry for a long long time he's crazy
talented and we start off making props
for LA I'm live action role play and
then I discovered cosplay and I was like
okay this was a great industry because
foam latex is perfect it's safe it's him
the cons don't mind him it's not worried
it's heavy you can carry it all day so
yeah the people starting out what would
you recommend kind of tips and tricks of
the trade for cosplay the best thing I
would say is research do your research
work out exactly what character you want
to do Google is great
we just go on there print out all the
images and make sure you're just
prepared yeah and have fun because
that's what it's all about what a great
message now what would you guys come up
to your Game of Thrones fans like to see
in season 4 of a see season 3 not
unfinished well I must say Jamie
Lannister is really growing on me and
the relationship he has with him
Rick conflicts now it's an area yeah I
really hope their relationship gets
stronger
so yeah very interested to see
how about you as a well basically the
inn for the king and the White Walkers
take over the world because they
probably will everyone dies
and here we Daenerys like to see on the
train Daenerys you're my side yeah
falling out here between the car link
ilithyia if you could have anyone bumped
off next season who would okay I stopped
dying I'd like these characters stop
killing our home kid ah
Joffrey only because he's uh he reminds
me of that little gift from Harry Potter
slippery
but fair dues in real life people are
actually trashing his house and in
deficit everyone leaves sweet tooth in
the show said Jack needs new plays was a
really really lovely lad but he did such
a good job
Joffrey's really announced in there I
mean good on him he's doing a flat and
dropping yeah and any of the characters
in the show that would take heavy love
and I'm interested to see where Aria
goes and I loved the saw Donna the sort
I hope he comes back you don't see him
die so I'm not read the book fingers
crossed he'll make another appearance
love to see Syrio Forel back he was
brilliant wasn't it yeah and if you
could sit on the throne who would you
like by your side here you have your
king because over the the car your dad's
I'll bring him back to life I did black
magic you know
you